aboard ape once worth 350 000
for a
a jpeg of a
ape
which sold for 350k now just sold for a
paltry 115
and people naturally are suspecting uh
something's going on so explain this how
does something like this happen you
bought this board for 350 grand and now
less than two years later is worth 115
dollars is this a mistake is it are they
missing a zero
collective belief bro people were buying
and giving a price to these because they
believe the community would bring to
fruition something beautiful like the
platform that they just created as an
example on the other side uh and you
know they built a community a lot of
celebrities got involved that has a
price tag it's like you know so house a
membership club right you have to pay
but then again to what you mentioned uh
minutes ago the beauty of crypto
is that there's no centralized
you know lobbyism or manipulation in the
market the guy that sold for 115 dollars
sold for that price to prove
that it's still early you can still get
in the space you can still control your
assets so you think he was being
philanthropic taking it
for fun hey guys listen i just want to
prove it to everybody oh i swear to god
stop it
the guy you're saying took a 350
thousand loss so people understand
who the hell would do that guy if i go
on open scene and i see his address i
bet you that he has probably 10 bar dips
i bet you he has 10 board apes and he
sells that one for that price just for
the sake of showing there's no control
in this i decided to sell for this price
this is what i think it's you know
reasonable and it's sold what an amazing
person what a what a kind-hearted man
doesn't make that 350 k left he maybe
sold he maybe owed that other guy some
money and like
now the debt's like oh there's
definitely some money hustling scamming
going on with nfts
you're saying there's money laundering
that's money learning too it's possible
so well that wasn't going to as an nfc
i
so as a money as a nft guy is it fair to
say that there's definitely some shady
stuff money laundering going on
traditional companies for all shell
companies like everywhere yeah sure so
we're saying hey you know follow the
money it's good
people but bro i know people yeah that
know that would do this like for sure
just for you know
you have some nice friends introducing
yeah so these are these are kind-hearted
philanthropic money laundering nice
people not money laundering don't say
that because you know my legacy can come
after you
creative uh you know
record-keeping no i'm just saying that
for the sake of like
you know getting the market
i control my assets i know people will
do that pretty shady pretty shady but
hey respect that's why we brought you on
here leia you want to weigh in on this i
mean i don't know i i guess it depends
what the floor price is so i don't know
what the floor price is it's massive
it's 300k right so maybe he is correct
so the floor price is basically like
you know the floor prices yeah yeah i
don't know it's just it's just a base
level of what they go for right so if
he's clearly underselling it there's
obviously something going on there and i
think as well like with even with art
anyway art physical art is always
a loophole when it comes to taxes and
things like that so i imagine that this
is basically
the same loopholes probably apply for
digital art
um you're saying he's taking a tax loss
i don't know what he's doing he's just
taking a loss and he's just writing off
350 grand i think he's being smart
this guy's being smart oh creative
creative creation it's for the splash
all right
in my mind you bought it at 350 you sold
for 115. doesn't seem smart but you're
like there's an underlying story going
on if the floor price is still up yeah
then that's then then the board ape is
holding its value and it's not crashed
regardless of that sale you can accept a
bid and sell it but you know the floor
price is still high there's no this just
shows me there's no forced transparency
with this so if that's what you do and
you want privacy i mean
that's one way to go about a wealth
transfer in that way okay and it
be written down some kind of way you
guys are good with this yeah all right i
just learned something today that
everything that i thought i understood
about money makes no sense you buy a 350
you sell for 115 great deal i don't get
it but hey i'm learning
[Music]
you